a writer on Sesame Street earlier in the  week claimed that Bert and Ernie are gay  and so now Sesame Street's been  responding to that the producers of  Sesame Street said Bert and Ernie do not  have a sexual orientation okay now I  always thought it was pretty obvious  that Bert and Ernie were gay I did  personally I think you did too  especially based on some of the  appearances they've made over the years  for example they were guest judges on  RuPaul's Drag Race I don't know if you  ever saw that yeah that's a true story  yeah very yeah they they hosted an  annual summer solstice party on Fire  Island true great party I was there they  officiated Neil Patrick Harris wedding  they officiated of course there was Bert  sham marriage to Liza Minnelli that  didn't fool I love that can we see that  picture again I just want can I have a  copy of that I just and then finally  there was the time they appeared on the  cover of out magazine we should have  seen it there  [Applause]  you